[Music]
well this is a big night years of hard
work the movies still so iconic and now
it's a musical how does it feel to be
here it's really exciting to be here I
feel a little bit like it's our wedding
again because like we're like okay who's
got Grandma wear it like we've tried but
and really could I'm really excited for
this young cast for people to see them
they're so good I know this is a tough
question but if you had to choose your
favorite line from the movie and can you
recite a for us as the character it's
not for a know if it's broadcast of all
but it's my favorite line I usually say
it's um it's not my fault that I have a
heavy flow and a wide-set vagina
somebody wrote in that book that I'm
lying about being a virgin because I use
super jumbo tampons but I can't help it
if I've got a heavy flow and a wide-set
vagina yeah I can't do this my favorite
to also want to ask you could we see any
of the original cast come on scene have
you talked to Rachel Orleans yeah I
think Daniel Prince andis coming next
week and we unload all of them and sort
of said like doors open whenever you
want to come
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]